just when you think things can't get any
stupider they do on Sunday President
Trump tweeted out a gif of himself
clotheslining someone knocked me into
the ground then pummeling him at an old
WWE event in the gift the head of
Trump's victim has been replaced with
the CNN logo so Trump appears to be
tackling then beating the hell out of
the network in most despises the one
he's used as a foil in his rise to power
Trump CNN tweet followed on the heels of
his tweets from last week in which he
attacked MSNBC's Mika Brzezinski and Joe
Scarborough in the most personal terms
Trump supporters responded with
unrestrained leads much of this Trump
was fighting back CNN meanwhile
responded with the typical restraint and
objectivity reporter after Reporter
declared the Trump's we didn't merely
represent an obvious breach of decency
and unpresidential and apparently
pathological outburst of spontaneous
rage tweeting it promoted violence and
Trump would have blood on his hands if
some rogue follower picked up a gun and
decided to come after brian Stelter
Trump supporters responded to this
outpouring of faux rage by CNN by
shouting about Kathy Griffin carrying
around a bloodied mop head of Trump
Julius Caesar presented by Shakespeare
in the Park
as an assassination of Trump and
Democrats from coast to coast to
proclaim that Trump care would end with
grandma being shoved off a cliff by
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan in this
Kabuki theater both sides are right in
both sides are wrong the media are right
the president is acting out in a fashion
that makes my three-year-olds temper
tantrum seem mature by comparison Trump
supporters are right that the media's
coverage is so wildly corrupt and
hysterical
it makes Leo bloom and the producers
look like Mother Teresa the media are
wrong that their liberties are some sort
of existential assault from the
president who's merely mouthing off the
way he has this entire career
Trump supporters are wrong that all
evils can be excused by simply pointing
at the latest media bad actor and
yelling war are at the top of your lungs
so here we are a media nobody trusts
school harming a president who's the
class clown nobody looks really good in
this particular fake wrestling match the
question is actually why anyone engages
in it at all after all we know the match
isn't real from so adores media
attention that of CNN and the New York
Times were to stop covering him he
quickly set himself on fire outside
their studios for the cameras likewise
if Trump were to stop tweeting CNN would
have to go back to covering missing
Malaysian airliner it's a romance made
in hell but the ratings are absolutely
stellar so the question remains why does
everyone treat this game as if it's
being played for high stakes
well it's entertaining and entertaining
conflicts must have clear good and evil
combatants because the media are corrupt
in trouble
mature both sides must willingly blind
themselves to the faults of their
favorite characters so the right says
the Trump of the virginal political
victim a neophyte undeserving of his
critics vitriol even better he's held up
as an unparalleled political genius the
voice of the people the populist
revolutionary and the guise of the
prince of the city a sort of Bruce Wayne
who down at the Cape of Justice by night
and tweets raged the media by day while
the music from The Dark Knight thunders
dramatically in the background the hand
will affect from stopping the Joker
Hillary never fades in the eyes of Trump
supporters meanwhile the press overlooks
its own participation in the corrupted
political entertainment complex in order
to paint itself as thoroughly
painstaking an objective in its work
journalists see themselves and left
flatteringly sees the journalists as
warriors for truth exposing the light in
every dark nook and cranny of the Trump
administration they imagine themselves
in battered hats and trench coats
walking around in the rain looking for
all of the evidence of the dark deeds
uncovering the seedy side of Trump aney
Hall the halo effect from opposing Trump
never dies further the Fourth Estate
this Manicheans dichotomy means that
there is no way for any reasonable or
tempered debate to emerge over proper
behavior or coverage instead there's
Glee for Trump's base in watching Trump
bring justice to the streets of media
Gotham winning VAT orangs masseur back
nastiness at Mika Brzezinski's bloody
face and for the media there is similar
Glee in proclaiming Trump and incipient
Hitler a Willie Stark who must be
stopped before it can transform into
real life Huey Long all of this makes
the political scene a lot more fun and
entertaining but it's not very useful
well the drama of Trump versus the media
is amusing it's not quite WWE quality
because most people actually think that
it's real we can find the WWE
entertaining and amusing because we know
it's scripted but if we actually thought
it was real and then all of a sudden we
were rudely disabused of that notion it
would probably ruin the fun the same is
true of our politics right now the
realization that Trump versus the media
is just overblown stupidity half
scripted on both sides makes the
conflict less compelling the comedy
actually becomes kind of tragic after
all it's a lot easier to laugh at the
antics of the undertake Undertaker than
to laugh as the office of George
Washington and the industry of ernie
pyle both become punchlines i'm ben
shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
okay so the CNN has completely let
itself on fire so yesterday was July 4th
and in honor of Independence Day she and
then held the fireworks celebration in
its own pants it lit all of the TNT that
I could find and then proceeded to blow
it up absolutely destroying itself
wholesale we will talk about all of it
because it is really amusing I just said
we shouldn't talk so much about the WWE
stuff but I'm going to because it's
hilarious oh we'll talk about all of
that stuff in a second but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
blinds comm so I'm sure you don't think
too much about your blinds but let's
face it they're really ugly and you need
to replace them because they've been
there for like 20 years and they're left
over from the previous tenants or the
previous owner you never bothered
because who cares about blind you should
care about blinds because they make your
home look so much better when they are
bad you need to replace them as what
blind scum does for you they make it
really easy if you're not sure what you
want or even where to start you go to
blind comm you get a free online design
consultation that you send them pictures
of your house they don't send back
custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme your furniture
specific rooms but we even send you free
samples to make sure that what you see
online actually looks as good in person
as it does online and if you miss
measure you measure it yourself even
this measure it blinds will blinds comm
will remake the blinds for free so you
can screw it up and it's your fault they
will make sure that it gets done right
for a limited time go over to blinds
comm and use the promo code band you get
20% off everything all of the things 20%
off when you go to blinds comm using
promo code then again that's faux wood
blinds cellular shades roller shades and
more 20% off everything when you use
blinds calm promo code Ben again that's
blind SATCOM promo code Ben rules and
restrictions do apply but make sure you
use that promo code Ben so they know
that we sent you and you helped support
the program okay so CNN just it's
astonishing how basically I tweeted last
week that Trump destroyed CNN not by
actually attacking them by trolling them
so hard that they destroyed themselves
he really gave them enough rope that
they decided not just to hang themselves
but to hang themselves by the neck until
they were nearly dead then pull
themselves up back onto the platform and
jump repeatedly this is basically what
CNN is doing now so here's how this
works out
over the course of the weekend so on
Sunday president Trump tweets something
that I assume my three and a half year
old daughter has the good sense not to
tweet a WWE wrestling graphic
of himself tackling a person with a CNN
logo for a head and then jumping on top
of them and pummeling them right the
President of the United States let me
forget George Washington and Abraham
Lincoln once sat well George Washington
did but Abraham Lincoln once sat in the
office where Joe where Donald Trump is
tweeting in the middle of the night from
the toilet presumably about racially so
so he tweets this and here's what it
looks like everything is so stupid okay
so he tweets that and then he and then
he enjoy for its independence day he
said to double down on that he starts
mocking the fake media which is his
favorite thing to do right he's he North
Korea may be firing the intercontinental
ballistic missile capable of hitting
Alaska but he's got to hit the fake
media I mean come on so it's the
Independence Day and in the middle of it
see she jumped out that he starts
ripping on the fake media all right the
fake media is trying to silence us but
we will not let them because the people
know the truth the fake media tried to
stop us from going to the White House
but I'm president and they're not okay
so that's their I mean the media hated
him they tried to stop him from going to
the White House and now they're trying
to take him down all that is fair
they're not exactly silencing him he's
pretty loud it turns out and he uses his
Twitter a lot so that really doesn't
change anything but yes the media are
bad yes the media are obviously trying
to cover him in unfair fashion so he
tweets this stupid thing about wrestling
the media has an obvious response they
could say mr. president that was a
stupid thing to tweet maybe you don't
have a lot of self-control that would be
true it would also be obvious and it
would be relatively objective instead
they proceeded to spend the next three
days talking about how this means that
Donald Trump wants to literally go and
beat brian Stelter spacing right it
really he's a sick Nazi who wants to
murder people and that's why he's
tweeting outwrestling tweets from the
WWE like I'm first of all it doesn't
make any sense to me they use the CNN
logo over at Miz Vince McMahon's face is
CNN's logo a person like how can you
even hit CNN's logo it's a
it's not a say it's not a person like
how unless brian Stelter changed his
face and had surgery I can old Twilight
Zone episodes and now his face looks
like the CNN logo I don't see how anyone
would identify one with the other but in
any case the left went hysterical so
Howard Dean says it's just right-wingers
and they want to shoot places up it's
all because of Trump it's Trump and he's
a Nazi so it's not enough for them just
to say that Trump is is ridiculous in
how he uses Twitter which is obviously
for no no he's evil and he's a Nazi and
then you'll see they went even further
because they're totally insane they've
lost their minds
Trump has trolled them so hard that they
have actually become that which they
fear so here is Howard Dean first saying
that Trump is evil and violent a lot of
the Trump voters are not the far-right
nutcases with guns who want to you know
shoot up the place
most of the Trump voters are be anyone
was defining them that way know what
there certainly are some of them and the
NRA put an appalling ad out there which
really didn't basically made this a mini
okay so what the Howard Dean who's a
complete is talking about how the
right is full of violent people
let us unless we forget three weeks ago
a Trump hating Bernie Sanders supporter
tried to assassinate several dozen
Republican Congress people but were the
violent ones right
it's the Trump supporters who are the
violent ones those of us on the right
who are the violent ones okay so Trump
tweets out this WW thing and medias
first reaction is Trump is violent and
then they get their second reaction so
it's not enough for them to be clown
themselves the first way they have to
proclaim themselves every way they have
to find new ways to bolon themselves
every single day so what do they do
CNN goes CNN goes ahead and runs a story
trying to find the source of the main
right because Trump didn't create this
little video of himself tackling the CNN
logo somebody took the WWE video and
pasted the CN and logo in there so where
did he get it so he got it supposedly
according to CNN from some guy at reddit
for those who don't know reddit sort of
an underground political thread it's
very big website a lot people visit it
are the Donald is where all of these
memes pop up and I sort of have a
love-hate relationship with other than
Arnold sometimes they like me sometimes
they don't
it's always an inverse relationship with
how nice I'm being to Trump that day so
I'm sure they'll love this episode in
any case are the Donald posts this meme
there's a guy whose name is I can't
actually say it out loud because it's
cursing it's Han bleep whole solo okay
and this is now national
media coverage we have to discuss these
things because this is everything is
stupid so he puts out this meme right
hon bleep hole solo puts out this meme
and CNN traces it back to him and then
CNN goes and looks at all the other
memes that he's put out and turns out
he's put out a bunch of racist
anti-semitic names because there are a
lot of people on reddit who do this I
know because I was the personal
recipient a 40% of all anti-semitic
memes that were tweeted on the Internet
at journalists last year I personally
was the recipient of so I'm well aware
of this entire crowd I mean well aware
of the bleep posters as they call
themselves in any case they decide to
dig up all of this ancillary material
and then pretend that Trump is somehow
linked to that so first of all this is
bad journalism it's bad journalism
because it would be one thing if Trump
tweeted an anti-semitic meme and then
they said okay here is the world of ants
Medic memes from which he is drawing
that would be able to good story right
or if they'd said he keeps going over to
Reddit and 4chan he has a long-standing
relationship with Reddit and 4chan where
he takes their memes why is he so warm
toward these people that's a fair story
what is not a fair story is he picks up
one piece of material from the art
Donald thread and now we're going to
find the person who created that who
Trump has never met probably never seen
and never in none of this came like some
probably had no relationship with this
person ever he doesn't know who they are
from Adam and then we're going to find
everything that guy ever did and then we
are going to wink all the bad things
that I did with Trump right you can see
how far they're stretching so already
this is a stupid story already this is
an idiotic story Trump didn't tweet
anything racist or anti-semitic he
tweeted something dumb and now they're
trying to link him with racism and
anti-semitism because the original
creator of this wrestling Jeff gif was
was some schmuck who tweets out
anti-semitic racist stuff okay so that's
dumb in and of itself but then they go a
level dumber okay I told you things are
just going to get stupider from here on
it
right eventually as I said last week
America will disappear because we all go
brain dead from loss of IQ points due to
following politics too closely because
this is all so stupid so it goes a level
deeper in the stupidity so now CNN
doesn't just crack down on a whole solos
name right they tread dancers track down
who he is
they don't just track down what else
he's tweeted now they go to him and they
reach out to him and he immediately sees
what's happening he sees they're not
going to target him and so what he
decides to do is apologize so he puts a
big apology he takes down
all the terrible tweets it takes then
all of the terrible memes and then CNN
prints the story and here is what they
print ok this is from the CNN story
direct quote quote CNN is not publishing
Han a-hole solos name because he is a
private citizen who has issued an
extensive statement of apology showed
remorse by saying he has taken down all
his offending posts and because he said
he is not going to repeat this ugly
behavior on social media again in
addition he said his statement could
serve as an example to others not to do
the same
CNN reserves the right to publish his
identity should any of that change okay
so for those of you who missed what just
happened that's called blackmail right
what CNN is doing now is they're now
saying he took down all of the stuff
that we didn't like he took the racist
ancestry to come on CNN and stuff but
should he renege should he become a
recidivist a reddit recidivist he'd
become a meme recidivist should he go
out on the streets and threaten America
America again with other WWE linked
videos then we will reveal his name to
the public at large right CNN reserves
the right to publish his identity should
any of that change what so now they've
taken what was an obvious and clear win
on Sunday right Trump making fun of them
with some stupid meme and they could
make fun of him back and it's an obvious
one and they have destroyed themselves
three separate ways first by claiming
that Trump is violent and this is
promoting violence second by trying to
track down everything possible about
this mean guy and third by then
threatening the meme guy that if he
doesn't back down from this they are
going to out him right that is it so CNN
has now blown all journalistic
credibility out of some pathetic sick
attempt to get Donald Trump and anyone
who is remotely linked with Donald Trump
that's how insane all of this is I mean
it's totally crazy and this is what
Santa's doing but wait it gets even
better
okay so just keep going the story gets
even better but before I tell you the
rest of the story I have to say thank
you to our sponsors over a tracker so I
am a person who is incredibly
absent-minded which is why I have to
have two people telling me every morning
what I'm doing that day and that does
not include my wife we didn't really
have to build a company you tell me what
my schedule is every day because I'm so
absent-minded I lose my wallet phone and
keys all the time and it was time you
get frustrated my wife also has a
tendency to do that so we stare at each
other in annoyance on a frequent basis
wondering where we put our stuff and
that's why our marriage has been
improved dramatically by the
by traveler trackers just great what you
do is you take this tracker device like
a coin size device you stick it on your
keychain and then it connects to your
phone with a program and you can hit
this button on your phone and now your
keys will start beeping and you can find
your keys or if you lose your phone then
you can actually hit the thing on your
keys and that will link to your phone
and even if your phone is on silent
right the tap install the time you lose
your phone it's on silent you can't find
it instead it now rings through so
you'll never lose your wallet or your
phone or your keys again your marriage
will be better you will become a better
person I promise that your marriage will
if you're on the verge of divorce now
you'll have the most glorious marriage
that ever was thanks to tracker because
that's just what they do you're never
going to lose this stuff again tracker
changes everything so they have
something new that's called the tracker
pixel and the tracker pixels lettuce
Bluetooth tracking device on the market
again put it on everything and it'll we
put it on our baby so that we don't lose
the baby
and you'll never lose anything again
right now you can get the third they
also have a 30-day money-back guarantee
go to tracker comments TR ACK are calm
the tracker calm and for that promo code
Ben you get 20% off any order you choose
that the tracker comm promo code Ben for
20% off the tracker comm promo code Ben
and you're never going to lose anything
again which for me is an important thing
and I think it will be for you as well
okay so we are we're through three of
the four steps in cnn's total self
macleod i mean at this point the only
way to describe this is that they
deliberately decided to kick themselves
in the groin as hard as humanly possible
and now all their appendages are out of
order because it just continues okay so
here's where it goes from here now CNN
defends itself from the blackmail
accusations he no no no we never
blackmailed anyone he said we decided
not to publish the name of the reddit
user out of concern for his safety
here's the problem you also threatened
to release his name if he changed his
behavior so where is the safety threat
coming from now CNN it's coming from you
because you're threatening to release
his name if he doesn't obey you but
that's not the bad part okay that's not
the bad part here is the worst part they
got the wrong guy okay they got the
wrong guy to try it they tracked down
Rebel Alliance hero Han a whole solo
they tracked him down on planet Endor
and then they failed to get the right
guy they got the wrong guy the BuzzFeed
here's BuzzFeed reporting
this is amazing according to BuzzFeed
quote one user pointed out that what
Trump tweeted wasn't actually Han a-hole
solos gift
Trump's gift included both video and
audio whereas the rebel smuggled
wannabes gift did not include audio
furthermore the original Han a whole
solo gift was shorter had a different
aspect ratio and had a WWE logo in the
corner not even the colors are processed
in the same manner
han Solo honeyhole solos gift has an
NTSC aspect ratio because it was cut
directly from the taping of an analogue
West at WrestleMania footage Trump's
video has an aspect ratio of 16 to 9 and
it continues someone downloaded the gift
that Han a whole solo originally posted
to Reddit the person cropped it to
better fit a video player like Facebook
or YouTube they went through the effort
of syncing it back up with the audio
from the original clip then they put it
where Trump or one of trumps people
could see it and download it so in other
words something you can get it from
reddit ok Trump got it from Facebook
Trump got it from Facebook or from
YouTube and then you put it up so their
friends link this guy who made it on
reddit who's not linked to Trump in any
way they're trying to link to the
ancillary stuff that Trump has never
seen to Trump in order to call Trump a
racist anti-semite and then they got and
then they're threatening the guy and
they got the wrong guy
come here no this is just it's sheer
incompetence of the highest order and
all this does of course is it helps
Trump but I mean Trump is just sitting
there going I've been calling them
taking use all the time should I say the
fake news even when the reporting we do
stuff but now they're big news all the
time it's just like could he have paid
them like Trump doesn't even have to buy
them because he now owns them right or
if he doesn't own them they self owned I
mean it's just it's unbelievable it's
just incredible and that wasn't by the
way even that is not the end of the
story because yesterday CNN 2 times 2
times apparently had fake quotes one
from Abraham Lincoln you know dumb you
have to be to run a story that is a fake
quote from Abraham Lincoln kiss on she's
making new stuff up every day Abraham
Lincoln tonight he's coming out with new
material that you have to bet isn't dead
for 150 years
I mean president from may not know that
he thinks Andrew Jackson still alive and
so Frederick Douglass but but the fact
is that Abraham Lincoln I think Trump is
aware that he's dead and certainly CNN
should be I mean no the one saying Trump
is so stupid he so don't quote Abraham
Lincoln when he's not saying news that
it's just it's unbelievable
and then everyone wonders why trust in
the
maybe declining I can't imagine why
trust in the media is declining so when
we continue on the other side here I
want to talk about some Republican
silliness that happened over the weekend
also on the media because we can't just
have Republicans have gone we've gotten
the point where the tensions be partisan
silliness there have to be bipartisan
silliness like everyone has to drink the
kuku juice and now everyone has lost
their minds so we'll get to more
insanity July 4th insanity but first
you're going to have to go over to Daily
wire and subscribe so for eight dollars
a month you too can become a subscriber
to daily wired.com that gets you the
rest of the show live against you the
mailbag which we're doing on Friday
if you enter Clayton's show live as well
as the mailbag we're launching some
other shows too plus you get the ad free
experience on the website which is
awesome and you get all that for just
eight dollars a month make sure you lock
in your subscription now because our
rates are going up on July 10 if you
want the annual subscription you get a
free signed copy of the book I wrote
with my dad's say it's so about baseball
and fathers and sons really fun book and
I will autograph it for you can treasure
it you can keep it forever handed down
to your grandchildren or alternatively
sell it on eBay for a profit I won't
tell you what to do with it in any case
you can get that for free when a Pony
annual subscriber or just one to listen
later in iTunes or SoundCloud then go
over there subscribe leave us a review
we always appreciate it make sure that
the way you should we've reviewed by the
way is however many stars you think the
show deserves add 5 to it and then leave
a review because that's the best way to
do it in any case you can join us on the
other side when you subscribe we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you